[MUSIC]
The way memory works is
in terms of snapshots.
I don't remember the entire experience.
I remember moments in that experience.
And why is that so critical?
Because it tells you that what you
need to manage is not the film but
it's a specific kind of moment.
What people most remember is that end.
Overall, people rate colonoscopies that
take longer but end less painfully
better than colonoscopies that
are shorter but end more painfully.
It doesn't matter how long something took,
it matters how it ended.
They remember the end which we've talked
about, but they also remember the peak.
It's something called The Peak and
End Rule.
People take those two
pieces of information and
that's how they remember an experience.
You can think of you go to Disney,
you go on the ride, that's an up, and
then you wait in line, that's a down.
You go from sort of location to location.
It's not kind of the uniform experience,
it has all kinds of spikes, okay?
And it has kind of moments in which
experiences naturally break up.
So if you think in terms of peak and end,
you want to break up an experience when
you're near the top of something, right?
So then when I think back as
a customer about my entire experience,
what I've quoted in my head
is a series of peak moments.
A lot of companies forget
the importance of finishing strong.
Hotels, they'll do a lot for
you when you come in, but
then when you check out that process
isn't really managed, right?
It would actually be smart and appropriate
for them to give you a departure gift.
So remember any kind of customer
experience that you have,
go back to your desk after this webinar
and ask yourself, how do we finish?
How does this thing end?
>> Understand how consumers experience and
rewire your approach to marketing.
Learn more about The Emerging CMO:
Strategic Marketing Leadership.
[MUSIC]